[Musique]
et la culture la parité au style que
révèle qu'il a dédiée
j'ai pas bien cela
[Musique]
la culture trouverez d'une opa gars
revendications directement nullité tout
cas
3 malheureusement on le croirait un peu
c'est impressionnant
je dirais pas joli mais impressionnant
de voir ces machines qui tournait avec
ses grosses bobines
tournai les fils qui passait dans des
espèces de ronds comme ça un peu vous
savez comme au cinéma
des bobines le gars qui passait le film
beaucoup et ça défile à une vitesse
phénoménale
c'est pour ça que ça faisait du bruit
c'est comme ça
c'était une usine où je me plaisais me
disait la rodia 10 et parodié états
était trop long je regrette mon art
hogan
elle me manque bien que retraité on
reste encore les regards et les royals à
huy il retourne très facilement
j'aimais bien mon boulot mais ça veut
pas dire qu'il y avait pas de problème
il n'y a pas d' usine où il n'y a pas de
problème si elle n'avait pas fermé
j'y suis encore et ici a besoin sous
fabriquer quatre mille tonnes par mois
de fils et de filles mais vous pouvez
faire conduire de constituer avec ça on
cherchait les métiers chercher les
outils comme utiliser quand tu entrée
dans cette usine ya plus rien les murs
c'est vrai qu'une friche comme ça aussi
il faut aussi grande et aussi autres cc
c'est parce que c'est qu'on fait c'est
plutôt les enseignes textiles qui sont à
un niveau 2 lorsque nous on a l'habitude
de travail sur les fichages aujourd'hui
on vient avec dédé grignoteuse tous cons
et ça sort ça va très vite
ça c'est un chantier qui va durer six
mois
je suis un peu nostalgique de
l'industrie française en avait avant
c'est démantelé c'est l'abandon ça fait
vivre et on voit que ça rentre de
partout la ville à avoir de fermer par
contre qu'il ya des fresques magnifique
à l'intérieur on voit qu'il ya des
artistes le gars qui dessine sans
franchement et ps ont assez fait à la
bombe
c'est ça quand vous passez de
cathédrales ça donne juste envie d'aller
voir
on est dans le colossal on est on est
dans le gigantisme
je trouve ces bâtiments sont beaux et
une espèce de majesté deux de ces
espaces de ses volumes mais des usines
aussi vaste aussi impressionnant qui l a
pas tant que ça surtout de cette période
là quoi sert des années 50
cette paire d'heures on l'a on la
méconnaît complètement raconte les
sottises la fable des trente glorieuses
etc
c'était là où on travaille et quoi on
imagine quand même des milliers de
personnes venant là tous les jours en
permanence 24h sur 24 parce qu'ils
travaillent en 4 8 rebonds et voir cet
état là bon tu as un sentiment de gâchis
voilà ça va être détruit pour moi
qu'historien du monde ouvrier à un
moment donné il faut qu'en france il
reste quelque chose de ce que ça a été
que la civilisation industrielle et qui
n'est pas fini moi ça me met vraiment en
colère
c'était grandiose quand on avait tous un
grand bâtiment tout ça dit tout ce
personnel est vraiment formule tu avais
des murs en bleu des murs rouges des
murs jaunes
comme je disais c'est très mondrian au
milieu du restaurant il y avait un patio
avec des arbres dans puis un jet d'eau
on voyait un peu de verdure là parce
qu'on ne voyait pas beaucoup de verdure
envoyée en guinée où ça détend des
pendant une petite demi heure c'était
pas une petite les signes montrent avait
toujours eu peur des grands ateliers 4
heures du matin tu te retrouves dans un
blockhaus qui est très illuminé et qui
qui te rend tout petit c'est tous ces
mecs qui rentrent à leur dit qu'ils
pointent kinks et puis qui se rendent
sur le métier
daniel henry et robert sont du post
d'après midi et vont relever leurs
camarades au travail depuis 4 heures ce
matin
pas d'arrêt comme une gigantesque ruche
l'usiné produit 24 heures sur 24 on se
perdait à l'origine je demandais aux
gars qui étaient dans les filatures de
l'atelier des tirages et les eaux une
dit tu continues tout le long au fond du
couloir alors on court et parce que
fallait paris mort par
urs font parce qu'elles savaient y avait
des coureurs partout c'était presque une
petite ville
ce qui m'a aussi choqué le plus c'est la
chaleur
âgés entre 30 et 35 degrés pas vraiment
dans des endroits très chaud jusqu'à 70
degrés de température ambiante
en plus tu as ce bruit quasi permanent
qu'on ne s'entend pas tellement c'est
assez violent immense effort et obligés
de crier pour t'exprimer
quand on voyait son but ces granulés
graduée la primaire qui se met son fils
ça c'est sa vie en ville comme salis
c'était beau à voir
joli la volée une fille qui coule la
piale elle et qui s'enroulent l'est tout
autant de beau beaton pilote autant le
machin il enlevait la bobine héros qui
le remettait une au puissant reporter
ninon du tergal la fille moi alors
j'étais au fil fin et on avait toujours
dans sa petite côte blanche qu'on
mettrait une petite pierre ponce parce
que quand on travaillait chez soi tout
ça qu on bricolait bain un tout petit
bout de peau lance à casser le fil cassé
la position fallait recommencer
alors on donner des petits coups de
pierres ponces pour que le doigt soir
bien lisse quoi parce qu'il fallait les
lancer comme ça sur le rouleau et ira
pourrait connaître quelqu'un pour en
discuter ligonnes intérêt quelconque
affaire de l'église de la 244e dont les
vives de la 204 et les costumes étaient
ils se tenaient un costume trois pièces
intériale c'était magnifique
le gars qui se promenait comme ça c'est
déjà un bon monsieur
[Musique]
tél
c'est un endroit qui rayonne qui se voit
de loin on se rend compte qu'il ya de
l'activité déjà ça titille un peu quand
on a quelques affinités avec le dessin
avoir même avec la bombe de peinture
et puis après c'est d'aider rencontrer
des gens avec qui tu vas pas nous qui
viennent pendant un coup à la rodia qui
sont déjà allés et ce côté exploration
en fait qu'ils étaient super intéressant
nous à l'époque quand on venait ici on
se posait pas la question
c'était notre terrain de jeu nous
appartenait quand je sors du boulot des
fois schoch chez des gens on cherche
surtout t'habiller près après a sauté
soit rhodia c'est à ça que je passe un
peu pour un extraterrestre de temps en
temps à chaque fois que du coup des
nouvelles salles des nouveaux des
souterrains des caves encore du foie je
fais gaffe que j'essaie de recherché
depuis trois-quatre fois je la trouve
plus est ce qui est sympa c'est que même
si on a l'impression que c'est un lieu
qui est mort en fait il est très vivant
ce qu'à chaque visite ont fait à ça
c'était pas là il ya une kg de câbles
bouger ah tiens une clôture là qui est
des gens sont passés par là et mes
chèques apparu il ya des tas qu'un
nouveau tag puis des fois on sait pas ça
sent la peinture c'est c'est vraiment il
ya tous les sens un peu qu'ils sont en
éveil s'asseyait la vue yahia liliane
oui parce qu on fait toujours attention
de ne pas être vus ne pas faire trop de
bruit
ça fait quand même qu'au début on sait
par la passerelle n'y avait rien de
fermé sauf que ma taille dr boucher
c'était bien mûres et 303 passe quelques
aménagements pour faciliter la vie vous
rentrez par le laboratoire et de quoi
est ce qui était vraiment sympa que
cette entrée c'est que c'est un espace
cloisonné
c'était une phrase ombre ce qu'il y
avait toute la végétation qui le
poussait au tour c'était extrêmement
feutrée ont passé la plan de la
passerelle le petit trou est encore plus
petit et la wii le gigantisme de la
rodia que la grande salle et c'était
vraiment je pense la meilleure entrée
qui a eu à la redire c'était une belle à
une belle entrée en matière
beaucoup de gens qui se baladent les
ismes ont certainement premier des
récupérateurs ont toujours nous ç'a été
notre cas aussi on récupère est un
conteur les blacks de machines-outils
raynaud instruction genre de choses qui
pouvaient encore traîner
[Musique]
mais aujourd'hui ça s'est transformé en
vraiment en un paysage encore plus plus
intriguant
parce qu'ils aient eu des générations de
gens qui sont venus peindre ici assure
sur 30 ans
je vais je vais passer un long moment à
chercher à essayer de trouver une
émotion à un certain endroit et ça peut
avoir un lien avec effectivement la
géométrie et tout ça mais aussi avec le
l'histoire du lieu
là par exemple quand je fais un graffiti
dans cette danse patio celui ce petit
endroit en fait qui était une sorte de
cafétéria si je me trompe pas l'idée de
dessiner un logo qui ressemble à celui
de rhône poulenc
pour moi c'est un espèce de petit clin
d'oeil à l'histoire
tu vas au lieu qui va être détruit et
finalement c'est de redonner en fait on
lui a pris quoi fin mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya quand même toujours ce souci
d'entretenir ainsi plus de lien avec le
contexte alors la bombe c'est marrant
parce que j'ai tendance à dire que c'est
de la peinture mécanique
effectivement la bombe et d'industrie
est une évidence quoi
et une photo 1891 et une photo 1958 hu
sans glace
[Musique]
il ya cinquante ans que le comte hilaire
de chardonnet chimistes et physiciens
membre de l'académie des sciences avant
jala soir qui passionne
[Musique]
je rentrais du temps des soirées et ben
ali sous abri c'était un peu genre de la
rodia mais c'est être malsain c'est un
merci puis ça s'est arrangé pour ont été
rongés par la scène les pays aborde des
thèmes plantaire ma mère travaillait
dans les années au début des années 30
dans le au soir y est elle menait à la
crèche pendant qu'elle travaillait elf
avait là les femmes la possibilité de
laisser leurs enfants ensemble
il y avait des jours on sentait
réellement le les soieries et il y avait
une odeur d'acide est à polluer
insultant
mais autrement c'était la bonne boîte 1
les soirées c'était la bonne ambiance
c'était humain c'était alors qu'après
c'est artificiel en violet et malgré mon
envie de travailler
c'était vraiment une bonne chose pour
besançon la rodia a donné du travail à
beaucoup de monde oui on était trois
mille deux cents personnes se faisait
vivre quinze mille personnes sur la
place envahie de piano de vie il y avait
des avantages pour les gosses pour un
tas de jeux sait jamais tant bien
travailler et gagner ma vie c'est grâce
à regarde c'est là on avait des
possibilités de salaire que l'on ne
gagnait pas ce n'est pas dans d'autres
endroits la regarder un petit peu a été
une locomotive pour à un moment donné
quelqu'un elle a été obligée de remonter
un petit peu les salaires j'ai pu
admirer les étoiles
[Musique]
je travaille en quatre et huit autres
états
le rythme des 4,8 alors on faisait deux
jours mardi vers 4 heures du matin les
disney jeudi vendredi
12h02
samedi dimanche lundi 24 heures
repos jusqu'au jeudi matin
[Musique]
juste le temps d'effacer la fatigue
pour retourner au travail brun d'emprunt
ça nous faisait un week-end tous les
mois mais quand on april rip au bout de
seize ans on s'en rend plus con on est
dans le val et puis moi ça me convenait
et le fait de travailler aux 4,8 pour
beaucoup c'était l'occasion aussi
d'avoir un peu plus de temps pour faire
autre chose comme un agriculteur souvent
certains faisait encore un petit travail
à côté il savait du tondu mais malgré
tout la vie de famille était quand même
perturbé certains disaient on n'a pas vu
grandir nos enfants
les quatre hits que j'aime mieux c'était
la nuit où les matins voilà je circulais
beaucoup à jallet à la série mettrie
portée des bobines puis c'est là que je
les ai connus
j'ai fait du baratin tout le monde
espère c'est connu comme ça plus elle
elle était mariée et moi j'étais mariée
au cepii ça tombait alors on s'est mis
ensemble y salsa fait 40 ans 42 ans
le chu avec elle puisqu'elle est comme
ça iab et fille deborah tout mais parce
qu'on était jeune quand on sortait avec
des gens sortent elles nous on allait
danser autonomie non je trouve que ce
serait un mouvement mais la rodia
j'ai touché les fouilles avaient et
rhodia des ouvriers on est allé sur la
terrasse en cachets on a touché les
lettres or je vous mettais au moins
maintenant choisi pour grimper
[Musique]
moi je me suis dit la première fois que
je rentrais mais c'est pas possible
c'est un film on se croirait dans un
décor de cinéma
tout simplement on se dit c'est pas
possible que ça puisse y exister une
chose pareille pour de vrai on a du mal
à réaliser la seconde c'est incroyable
tout simplement
je pense ya aussi cet imaginaire du
cinéma qu'on a vu le gamin tu vois les
premiers soit mal max le premier
terminator ou on se retrouve comme ça un
peu dans mes lieux après l'apocalypse
je crois que sa marque et puis du coup
on n'aura pas envie de venir se frotter
à ça ça va compter c'est assez poétique
finalement dans la vie nous en avril
je suis maçon donc ce que la semaine je
fais les murs et le week-end je pense
c'est mon petit délire je prends ma
petite journée loin de tout le monde ou
avec mes potes je suis dans mon petit
univers dans ma petite bulle avec ça
permet de faire le break
une belle frappe du michigan il te fait
qu'ajourner quand même la pression
depuis le roi du monde
personne va venir te faire chier de la
journée même s'ils n'étaient pas à
l'abri de voir débarquer la bac mais
c'est rare quand même
bon vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que
c'était interdit quand même il ya quand
même eu déjà un mort et un blessé il ya
trois semaines à un mois
un gamin qui place aussi au travers donc
on va vous demander quitter les lieux
parce qu'elles contrôlent on viendrait
comme toujours chacun convient dit qu'on
appelait les matériels la première fois
que j'ai donné rendez-vous à ma copine
c'était ici je l'avais croisé au bar et
je le dis demain je t'emmène voir un peu
ce que je fais dans ma vie quoi donc je
la mets ici pas trop qui fait de devoir
escalader tout ça parce qu'à un peu le
vertige mais pour que ça reste une
journée trop bien même si elle avait
sali son pantalon avec de la peinture et
que ça s'est pas conclue conclu ce le
jour même mais elle s'en souvient encore
donc c'était gagné
je
[Musique]
ici on a peur du temps on a un peu
soustrait de la réalité extérieure à 17
piges on arrive ici c'est comme si elles
n'étaient pas soumis à la même peu
d'auteurs sorte de liberté comme ça
d'être dans un endroit qui est qu'il eut
presque une autre civilisation comme une
civilisation perdue un peu il ya ce côté
exploration d'une dimension un peu de
scientifiques sur une planète où plane
est oublié c'est la fusion de voilà
comment la nature reprend le dessus
aussi
[Musique]
c'est la même poésie que les ruines
il ya ce côté paradis perdu un petit peu
mon paradis industriel mais la promesse
la prod est la promesse moderne qui
continent tire est laissée un peu post
apocalyptique
quand on se promène isme
c'est pour ça je comprends pas toute la
ville avait mur et où partout il arrive
encore moins à rentrer dans cette usine
depuis six ans les oui hélas le dimanche
il est le premier au-dessus et dans même
qui défie dizaine d'alpinistes l'aïd et
de piles au dessus avec des cordes y
descendait oui le long de la rhodiola
s'est déjà vu des jeunes avoir mis une
tête puis ce côté est au dessus parce
que j'avais du gravier et ses toits
terrasses chez dînes chiens
je pense qu'il ya un côté aussi on peut
un peu un peu egotrip un peu
égocentrique qui fait que l'altération
de voix farhad pas nous directement mais
en tout cas seront ce qu'on fait et puis
au delà de ça même un truc un peu plus
modeste mais les terrasses quand il fait
beau c'est un endroit on peut se faire
un petit barbecue ou pas entre amis on
se boit des bières fin c'est convivial
quoi alain rodier tu peux quand même
plaindre ou qu'il au soleil avec une
gestion la citadelle et sur les toits et
un peu trop kg
[Musique]
quant au couple si la décision des
tickets dessus il ya une minute heure
est en colonie
alors à fabriquer une partie quand on
amène au micro de plusieurs trucs leur
dernier c'est l'automation
on appelait ça accélération des cadences
c'est toujours les mêmes gestes les
mêmes même machine 7 jours elle
travaille chez nous sans voir sur la
même ville entend toujours les mêmes
disent les premières quinze jours que je
charrie vérité parce que les gens
étaient bien payés mais il y avait
beaucoup de grèves plus qu ailleurs que
sur la place ça faisait 21 dimanche
comme les grèves le thème c'était le
chômage bidon 1 ils nous mettaient au
chômage ou sans rémunération alors
fallait prendre nos congés etc
sacrifier un jour de congé c'était
quelque chose de sacré quand vous pensez
que pendant toute l'année et travailler
trois dimanches sur quatre il fallait
pas toucher à ça c'était pas possible
et voilà peu près cinq hommes - c est
donc un matin l'équipe b et l'équipe des
îles se rencontrent et décident là de
faire la grève avec occupation d'usiné
c'est parler syndical qui a démarré la
grève ce sont les gens et puis on est
resté à moi à occuper les in
l'appartement de jeunes délégués
le dc fait par leurs camarades de cours
de la grande grève des postes en 1967
c'est là que nous avions fait sa
connaissance que nous avions fait celle
de juillet alors tout jeune militant
cfdt
pour la première fois monté sur un
tonneau jd power souviens que j'avais
déjà j'étais très bref parce que j'avais
peur mais il paraît que vous avez été
brillant c'est sûrement parce que
c'était vrai mais dans le même laps de
temps toutes les boîtes du groupe vont
se mettant en grève
14000 personnes du textile ron paul un
textile se mettent en grève
tu vois la pression et puis il y avait
des taux nous devons tout était fermé
on était chez nous on était bien la
rodia cet acquis mais c'est à nous la
lui tant que j'existe al art hogan
qu'est ce que c'est de profiter de la
vie est ce que c'est d'avoir une
télévision une hauteur pas payé il n'y a
pas que les questions d'argent
il ya la question d'hommes et sa famille
hors de de plus en plus on nous fait des
tons fait de nous des soupes roller loi
qui n'est pas réfléchi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
faut pas oublier que c'était la première
usine occupée depuis trente-six c'est
pas rien tout au début je comprenais pas
tout ce monde là je parle pas bien
français au top je disais mais pourquoi
qu'on ne peut pas voir
non il faut pas longtemps il faut pas
longtemps mais pourquoi les gens
pourraient tout simplement être reconnu
qu'on les respecte un petit peu denses
qui sont dues sans cette société qui ne
te considère pas en qualité d'humain tu
te mets en rébellion
la rencontre avec d'autres faits que je
m'installe dans une démarche de
découverte
comment me défendre moi et à travers
mais les autres voilà c'était ça ma
démarche et les résultats tangibles ou
nationaux grave ce n'est pas 3 4%
d'alimentation obtenu de l'éducation
d'une génération de jeunes de vriendt
qui ont découvert dans l'identité de
leurs conditions l'identité de leur
lutte pour la première fois dans cette
usine il allait avoir la création d'une
maison de la culture qu'ils soient pas
sous la tutelle d'un ministre eh bien
c'était rhodia settat et là tous les
jours tous les jours tous les jours tous
les soirs il y avait un programme
culturel conférences films
théâtre des choses très variées qui
m'ont ouvert les yeux sur un monde que
je ne connaissais pas plus
on est une vingtaine et on va devenir
des grands copains du grand camarade et
on va militer culturellement
politiquement et syndicalement ensemble
voilà on l'avait 25 ans 30 ans on avait
le corps qui était en puissance on avait
la télé en puissance et accroître la
mesure où la greffe déroulé ça a été le
comité de soutien c'était le
fonctionnement de la bibliothèque
c'étaient les animations des vaincus
lurel la culture retrouvez d'une bagarre
de revendications exactement au même
titre que le droit au parlement ovonic
le droit à la culture
un pôle cep c'était d'abord un militant
culturel
c'était un intellectuel pop c'était un
intellectuel qui avait décidé de devenir
ouvrier essaie de nous a entraînés dans
une aventure d'exposition de d'activisme
culturel inter de la rodia pillées en
même temps il nous a fait connaître ce
cpu
il devait minutes et je crois au moins
23 heures par jour il avait toujours
quelque chose à faire quelque chose ré
écrire quelque chose a décidé
là c'était une découverte merveilleuse
puisque pour la première fois j'ai accès
à des choses que je n'ai pas connu
auparavant les beaux livres d'une belle
histoire
les beaux films etc etc etc voilà il
venait à la bibliothèque de 4 à 5 heures
du matin on a commencé avec les grands
peintres on a quand même aussi avec les
grands auteurs etc etc et on a appris en
alu on a on a débattu etc etc et ça nous
a amené si nous a emmené les mots parce
que quand on les prolos défaut on n'a
pas beaucoup mot animer la bibliothèque
c'est le prolongement je suis toujours
dans la rue hier pour mal l'esprit de la
ruche ashley toujours c'est un
patrimoine c'est la bibliothèque depuis
67 quoi les universités comme je disais
toujours c'est la rodia et puis la rue
on n'a pas fait rien fait d'autre
il n'ya pas trente-six chemins on est
régi par ça où tu y vas où tu y vas pas
[Musique]
vous aura vous en veux pas encore
terriblement à ceux qui se prennent un
peu pour des patrons et qui ne le sont
pas et ceux qui détiennent les capital
le capital on vous aura c'est la force
des choses c'est la nature et à bientôt
le spare ce que je dis en fait quand je
dis à bientôt j'espère c'est le manque
de liberté nous il y avait un carcan
terrible dans cette société
la plupart des gars sortait du service
militaire et ramenant des juges
oui un combat de soif de liberté
voulaient vivre autrement que nos
parents pour avoir un coup à bientôt
j'espère je me souviens assez bien parce
que ça j'avais été éblouis ce défi lancé
aux patrons avec avec la conviction
tranquille que de toute façon il ya un
sens de l'histoire et les marges de
l'histoire qui fait que les ouvriers
sont destinés à prendre le pouvoir et
que les patrons vont devoir céder la
place on est tellement habitué à
entendre rien rien n'est possible tout
est fini c'est la voilà et là il y avait
quelque chose d'une d'une conviction
tranquille qui était magnifique entendre
pourquoi militer contre qu avec qui et
comment elle avait tellement de choses à
dire et une nouvelle façon de les lire
un nouveau moyen une nouvelle arme alors
nous avons le défi mais c'est pas si
simple pour faire du cinéma militant on
s'est retrouvé entre militants c'est un
boulot en plus après huit heures d'une
usine en plus des réunions des pactes
décollage des souscriptions
elle avait mis le bras dans l'engrenage
depuis quelques temps déjà des équipes
de cinéastes venait à besançon nous
révéler les secrets de la beaulieu du
pentax et une agrafe au fur et à mesure
que nous avancions un fabrication notre
film nous rendions compte qui me serait
impossible de nous passer les
techniciens de cinéma avant ils étaient
quelques-uns à penser qu'il fallait
travailler pour nous nous étions
quelques-uns penser qu'il faudrait qu'on
s'en sorte sans eux
aujourd'hui nous savons que le cinéma
militant ne peut naître que de la
collaboration de militants ouvriers et
le cinéaste militant
chris marker au début il faisait un peu
peur parce que c'est un personnage mais
c'était quelque chose quelqu'un bon
hassan et c'est un écrivain réalisateur
ils étaient multiples mais qu'il avait
une tête ou qui était je pense que tous
ces hommes avait quelque chose de
particulier qu on ne trouvait pas dans
notre entourage propres
les marqueurs fait partie de ces
intellectuels artistes issus de la
résistance très politisée mais un moment
très anti colonialiste et chris marqués
il se promène sur cette terre de
contestation et c'est là où on marque et
à une générosité militante
il n'est pas là pour donner des leçons
dans une lettre à paul seb d'avril 67
dit la question c'est que les ouvriers
sont par deux faces ce cinéma là et donc
il n'est pas dans une démarche
d'appropriation il en démarche de
transmission
ça c'est une démarche militante ça donne
ensuite les groupes helvétiques
[Musique]
que les travailleurs de rendre compte
que tout journée cooper perdu pour la
production
aucune plan d'appauvrissement de couple
et une de mes chansons été fondée en
les groupes medvedkine c'est dire le
réalisateur est un collectif essai
collectif ce sont des collectifs
ouvriers là on est au dollar fait donc
on s'approprie une expérience mais on va
beaucoup plus loin
nous avons exposé nos revendications à
table nous sommes allés discuter avec la
direction un pas et nous devons
continuer notre lutte
enfin c'est parti avec ce film s'est
appelé class de lutte
c'est là que c'est merveilleux on voit
suzanne sur le mur
elle monte sur le tonneau que c'est le
cas de le dire mais le set sur un mur
et puis elle s'exprime cette expression
que si si bel ensemble ensemble ensemble
ensemble on a voulu faire la gréve
ensemble etc
c'est tellement tellement fort que c'est
l'âme du film quoi et tout d'un coup
elle se révèle en tant que femme et en
tant que militante
j'ai découvert je me suis aperçu aussi
que la culture c'était quelque chose
chaud et que dans le fond je n'irai pas
à une explosion car on dirait pas des
poèmes des choses pourquoi un moment
donné tu as des parisiens réalisateurs
techniciens du cinéma et des petits
prolos qui se rend compte qu'il passe tu
vois ça devait pas se faire ce truc là
et pourtant ça va se faire c'est une
chez pas au niveau cinéma et et l'humain
c'est des choses là qui se rend compte
c'est quelque chose d'exceptionnel quoi
voilà et si j'avais pas connu ces gens
là moi je serai pas je fais pas celui
jeu donc je suis aujourd'hui c'est ça
qui fait là qui fait la force
ces gens sont sont beaux et grands voilà
dans dance dance qu'ils sont en train de
vivre et de construire c'est quelque
chose pourquoi ils sont beaux et grands
parce qu'en fait ils sont en train de
s'émanciper
le couvercle est en train de se soulever
et dell voilà et d'être projeté et on
voit ces hommes et ces femmes en train
de se libérer et dire ce moment de la
libération de l'émancipation et la joie
transgressive qui a ça
com
c'est aura plus interne amis
vous avez bien
c'est elvis aux tournevis
tous ces plans là enfin je les ai
trouvés sous la poussière sous les
débris
et il y avait d'autres documents comme
cela des demandes d'intervention au
service 4 11 66 oui si on a le 15 4 68
équipera j'ai visité cette usine là
avant de visiter les musées à blues
ensemble on s'amusait info faut y aller
comme les monts musée du temps ces
musées de la rodia sept ans des machines
qu'ils étaient en vie à cette heure donc
on peut voir les différentes cultures et
donc on à l'escalier pour monter sur le
sur les différents étages donc là on a
un premier étage
doivent avoir un deuxième étage du pays
[Musique]
que m
des fois ces gens que je connais
quasiment pas je reçois un message race
qui paraît tu connais comment elle est
dans la roue des as état est ce qu'on
peut se voir un soir machin on va y
aller je suis heureux que pat ferai
quand je commence à envoyer les premiers
messages offre des basques et qui
craignent pas des vêtements qui
craignent pas une lampe torche qui saura
où est ce que je vais en fait ça
commence un peu à créer l'ambiance puis
après tu rentres dedans pareils sont tu
vois un peu dans les yeux je crois que
c'est ce que je suis j'ai même un odieux
qui commençait à tout casser là dedans
je retiens tout le temps wemmel du tout
à l'intérieur je peux faire des trucs
sans interdit par la loi mais du coup on
s'en fout parce que je viens c'est bon
on attends tu aimes pas tout détruire
il ya quand même des gens qui viennent
ici c'est vrai que c'est abandonner mais
il ya des graffeurs c'est un peu un lieu
de vie pour différentes personnes
j'ai emmené mon professeur de français
du lycée
ici je lui ai proposé de venir un jour
m'a dit pourquoi pas donc j'ai commencé
à lui de faire une mise en bouche si je
peux dire ça comme ça en lui montrant
petit à petit toutes les photos que je
prenais quand il est rentré
wahou tout simplement adoré la rodia
c'est évident que
que j'en serais pas là aujourd'hui si
j'étais papa c'est quoi en fait ça un
vrai lien avec mon travail de designer
parce que là on est dans l'usiné dans
les années où en fait tu vois la
production industrielle elle était elle
été fantastique elle était c'était
quelque chose qui était qui était
glorifier le plastic était pas encore
remis en question donc en fait il y
avait une présence de production et en
fait quand tu la donnes le bâtiment
comme ça tu le ressens tu le vois dans
toutes les traces qui sont restés ici
c'est la police school
et
[Musique]
j'ai mes visites
sympathique
et
la police m'a plu on a un truc dans le
graffiti sûr que tu fais un grave comme
ça qu'est la police arrive que tu as
juste le temps marqués stop bail de la
police trois films a été coupé par la
police mais c'est vrai qu'il s'imagine
des choses on seront c'est comme si on
rentrait chez quelqu'un et que on à les
imaginer sa vie quoi et c'est vrai que
d'imaginer une époque parce que en fait
les choses sont datées on arrive à
facilement les airs allez comprendre
ça laisse imaginer nous de ce cap tout
ça plus être dans le travail ça me
parait loi mois déjà
l'idée raid a payé entièrement tout le
monde bosse à l'usiné tout ça ça me
paraît être plus loin dans le temps au
final mais les trente glorieuses en fait
il sera industriel ça me paraît vraiment
être liés à cette période et côtoie le
bâtiment ça donne un peu raison qu on se
rend bien compte que c'est plus les
actualités au final on pourrait pas vrai
pas travailler des gens dans des
conditions du bâtiment
donc en fait ça arrange les choses
finalement assez nostalgique et nice ou
deux comme ça de petits temporalité un
peu imaginaire qui se créent quoi
on se demandait on se promenait vous
n'êtes rien j'ai dit c'est pas possible
qu'une usine comme ça ferme mais la
motivation est plus le même
voilà vous savez que ça allait fermer
alors ça ça cassait tout
vous êtes acte de présence est opposée
rien du tout va jeudi sur une quinzaine
de balles ans celle qui tourne et là il
n'est plus qu'une pluie après tout était
fini tout est arrêté
ce qui m'a fait mal au coeur c'est quand
j'ai vu des montées les machines pour
les envoyer au nord de la thaïlande au
nord de bangkok avec des ingénieurs de
relier à besançon pour aller les montées
là bas ça ça fait mal au coeur
on a été le laboratoire de la
mondialisation la mise en place de la
mondialisation
et quand on disait les gens nous
disaient vous mélangez tout parce que
bon on parle de la rodia mai à besançon
je ne sais combien de fermetures
d'entreprises dans le même laps de temps
on est libre on a eu l'héritier on a eu
le heureusement il ya eu à peu près dix
mille emplois supprimés en l'espace de
quelques années
ça fait quelque chose oui j'ai disque
aussi c'est fini on sait qui tu es là
sur une poignée de main et tout le
bordel paix faut tourner la page quand
nous avaient fait 20 30 40 ans dans la
même boîte
vous avez tout miser votre vie là dessus
et puis journal maire fera d'ailleurs
faut tout remettre en cause
ça fait beaucoup de choses quoi t'est
c'était la semaine avant noël 82 j'étais
le seul
chef d'atelier avec monsieur griots de
la filature qu'on était les deux
derniers on n'avait rien à faire un don
comme et restait plus personne n'a dit
directeur on s'en va le 1er mai dont
faisaient partie les deux le 1er mai 83
j'aurais bien voulu finir ma carrière là
60 ans moi aussi je ne tenais pas
particulièrement à quitter le boulot à
52 euros
c'est pas forcément très agréable mais
bon c'est comme ça quoi
à tous les ans je sais mon emplacement
là je veux bien est ici posée garde
je suis derrière nous ça sera une tuile
si j'en prends une sur la tête ça faut
aussi les boules comme on dit
enfin c'est comme ça c'est l'idée
ambitieuse sakho mais c'était comment va
bien soldats les anciennes à la même
place des anciens la regarder danser le
regard à l'avancé on leur dira oui moi
je rentrais ici j'avais 18 ans vous au
regard de plus maintenant c'est trop de
la comme ceux de l'armée contre al qaîda
nuisibles voire nathan comme ça on a des
belles photos non mais dans l'état où il
est ne faut plus laisser ça comme ça
c'est pas c'est pas possible c'est pas
beau déjà pour ce que l'on travaille et
qu'on est obligé de la voir quoi puis
convoi on était au travail et enfin
j'espère qu'ils laisseront un monstre
usines qui vont leur est monté pour
rappeler un peu la vie de cette usine
que la sortie fixée comme l'accès était
rentré pour le poste allemande dans
votre camp vous bien la télé comme
pascal angely fait là sa chaufferie elle
elle habite en face à brest va me donner
de la clarté
parce que c'est juste devant mm enfin
c'est pas très beau décor je reconnais
les médias brandão diable vauvert un bel
hôtel je suis d'accord
depuis tout à l'heure on me parle de
cette fameuse cathédrale à l'intérieur
quoi le mot il est important parce que
si les gens parlent de cathédrales ça
veut dire que non seulement ces vastes
non seulement ces imposants mais il ya
une grande heure là dedans peut-être le
mot sacré ne convient pas je sais pas
mais il ya quelque chose de à préserver
quoi il est mon toit les montes
c'est assez intéressant d'ailleurs la
puissance la puissance du lieu parce que
quand on s'en approche
on est fasciné quoi
[Musique]
c'est une étoile de pierre au sommet de
la colline qui domine besançon les
fortifications des bovins d'une valeur
universelle exceptionnelle parce qu'être
au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco c'est
un magnifique
la belle nous vous faisons confiance
pour chérir votre bien pour le préserver
pour le conserver et qui somme toute ne
servira jamais servir d'école de cadets
de prison d'état l'a jamais servi à rien
on peut pas dire des choses comme ça
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
oh